what we're going to do is this I have
your attention
here's what we're going to do
we are going to start out with a word of
Prayer
then
you need to you need to get the the uh
the rules here for what we're doing
then I'm going to show you a video now I
want you to watch very carefully
okay
I want you to take in as much detail as
possible can you do that
are you ready for that
okay we're going to have a word of
Prayer
and then I'll go ahead and roll this
okay
our heavenly father I thank you so much
for another opportunity to come together
and study your word father I thank you
for the opportunity we had to get a
little bit of recreation and good food
and fellowship I pray now your spirit
would bless us in this time that we have
together may your name be uplifted we
ask it in Jesus name amen
now here's what I want you to do
I want you to take out a piece of paper
or your computer
and I want you to write down every
detail you remember from what you just
saw
okay I'm serious
write down what you saw
you're describing this to somebody write
it down
however you want to write it just how
just to convey it if somebody said hey
what was that video about and you're
trying to tell them what it was about
and you're giving as much detail I'll
give you a few minutes
okay
now
I want to hear what some of you wrote
okay I need some volunteers who's going
to volunteer for me all right
why don't you start
listen carefully you notice there's two
girls paddling and Dugout can do on a
river
next screen you're gonna see basically
is David in the studio with the TV
screen in the background this is added
veneer red
blue background
you're going to go to him
he's wearing a red red shirt with a
charcoal suit jacket
with the nose demand pulling teeth on
another man then goes back to David in
the studio and it goes back to uh
talk to the airplane
and then talking about a lady giving the
money he's going to purchase their first
airplane
and then we see a landing on a green
mode strip cut out of the Jungle a group
of people standing around the plane is
where it's parked and then the video
goes to then unloading the plane
okay good job excellent did you have
your hand up share with us okay tell me
what you've got we'll get to you next
Joshua Joshua right
I can't explain the story more
um there was a man explaining experience
where he hasn't gone it's an amazing
simultaneous circumstances God provided
specific needs for the man to reach out
to the people Guyana
he seem to be some sort of dentist and
also provide some sort of medical work
for people
almost resembled native Mexicans
okay
all right
Joshua I don't know I just said uh it
was talking about David Gates him and
his wife want to know God better so they
put themselves in a place where they see
him where him and his five kids took off
to Guyana to help the people in there
they paid for the supplies and they did
someone gave him the check for more
money than they spent they also needed
aircraft so they even negotiate with the
person if you want to buy the aircraft
on the way over someone gave him a check
for the whole park price was playing
when you gave it we'll be giving back to
you how do Brian go forward even when we
don't have anything
okay very good and what was your name
again Cindy that's right Cindy what do
you have
0.1
um a family gave up everything for God's
service they moved again for one year
gave us four attention to the local
Indian with the husband and wife with
five children they had enough support
point two God provides Community
um
point three we don't need to have
everything to move forward
um
they found that they needed to help the
Indians further than walking distance so
they were for us to come to the United
States to purchase an airplane they had
no money for it we found the airplane
that he was looking for to negotiate for
the airplane same day can you see the
check
with funds that were suspicious
okay question
who was right
almost everybody
was right
did they all say the same thing no
no they didn't all say the same thing
but everybody was right
okay
you've just had a mini experience of
what it's like
to be a prophet
okay
what we're talking about is the nature
of inspiration how does inspiration work
and uh
now did over here when Joshua went over
his thing did he give us the details of
for example how many kids
that the gates had
did he give us the number
did he give us the amount of money that
was paid for the plane
no did he give us the amount of money
that was needed for the whole project or
there was another figure in there did he
give us a lot of those details no
um but what he said was correct
and each person gave different details
right each one was correct you have an
understanding a little bit of how you
have four different Gospels
from the same story
you follow that okay what we're talking
about is inspiration and you should have
a handout that says the nature of
inspiration do you have that handout
you don't have that who doesn't have it
let me see where the extras are here's
one who doesn't have one
nature of inspiration okay
you should also have gotten a handout
not that we're looking at this right now
on the plagiarism charges you just came
up and I could have given you one of
these
there you go uh that we're not looking
at that right now but
here I'll open the door again I just I
wanted you to be able to hear what each
other was saying
okay
the nature of inspiration notice there
it says understanding how God
communicates with the prophet is just as
important as believing that God
communicates with the prophet
and you'll understand this as we go into
this a little bit more a belief in the
prophetic gift without a working
understanding of the nature of
inspiration will invariably lead to
misunderstandings misapplication of
teachings disillusionment and even
possibly even apostasy from the faith
and I'll touch on that as we go there
are three views
primary views I could say of inspiration
of how inspiration Works number one the
verbal or mechanical View
in the verbal or mechanical view of
inspiration the understanding is that
the information is dictated to the
prophet word for word okay God says you
write this and it's like okay God
thus thus says says the the Lord Lord so
on in right on down and the prophet goes
word for word dictation okay
you follow that okay that's the verbal
or mechanical view of inspiration
the second one list there is the plenary
or the thought View
in this Viewpoint God gives the message
to the prophet via Visions or dreams
but the prophet employs his or her own
words and expressions in communicating
the revealed message okay it is not
dictated word for word by God but it is
communicated
um in thought
and then the prophet puts it in his own
words now I'm going to tell you right
now that the plenary or the thought
inspiration model is what we as seventh
Adventists believe that God uses in the
scripture and in the spirit of Prophecy
and you've just experienced it
God shows the vision to the prophet and
then the prophet recounts what was what
was shown now there is a difference and
we believe there's a difference in in
that and what we've just done here and
that is that we do believe that God
guides the memory and the understanding
of the Prophet as they're communicating
the message
okay
but he doesn't verbally dictate it
do you follow what I'm saying there okay
the third Viewpoint there oh notice in
in Viewpoint number one this view does
not deny that on occasion the prophets
did indeed use the very words of God but
this was the exception not the rule can
you tell me a time where we know that
God dictated the words
and word for word the prophet repeated
it where it was verbal
uh I wouldn't say that
Ten Commandments clearly The Ten
Commandments the voice of God spoke now
here's the reason I say that Ezekiel if
you read about the account of Jesus
baptism you read different accounts in
the different gospels and here's where
you trip up on that if a person has a
verbal understanding that God dictated
word for word then how come Matthew and
Peter or Matthew in Luke and Mark in
their accounts of that all differ
they couldn't be true prophets because
if they were with a verbal under with a
verbal inspiration idea then they all
would have said exactly the same thing
because God dictated it to them do you
understand
and so this is what led many people to
be skeptical of the Bible Well the
Bible's not an inspired book why because
there's differences
well if you have a verbal understanding
of inspiration you've got some big
issues
but if you have a thought understanding
of inspiration you understand that as
God communicated it the prophets did
much like you just did trying to
communicate what you saw and each one of
you saw from a different perspective do
you follow that
okay
the third Viewpoint is the existential
neo-orthodox or the encounter view the
encounter view places a lot of emphasis
on your own experience
Revelation is an experience not a
message it's not so much about a message
that God gave it's some thrilling
experience you've received
an encounter with God I've had an
experience with God and I told you
earlier that I've had people come to me
oh yeah God speaks to me they were
prophets but they had this encounter
View
they thought I've had this I've had this
Rush of emotion and I think God's
speaking to me what's his message
there's no real message it's just that I
feel elated
and it must be God speaking to me notice
letter B there are no words spoken in
this view no information communicated no
statements of truth of any kind we may
say the prophet feels inspired as
opposed to actually being inspired in
this Viewpoint a person feels like
they're inspired of God and then thus
they feel that everything that they
communicate then must be truth from God
but the truth is subjective to the
prophet there's nobody to test it with
and so letter C in this view the
thoughts and words conveyed by the
prophet are merely his or her own and in
some cases may be entirely false as far
as reality is concerned
in the existential Viewpoint an example
is Moses literal Six-Day creation to
Moses
that was true for him
but in the reality of things we know
that the Earth wasn't created in six
days that's what an existentialist will
say when they when with their view of
inspiration you kind of follow what I'm
saying there their Viewpoint is that it
may be real to the prophet
but there's no absolute and it's not
really real to everybody
it's a personal experience that the
prophet experiences
letter D this view holds to three basic
principles number one inspiration is
inherently subjective rather than
objective God doesn't give a message the
message is really based on how the
prophet feels about it
and we could both be prophets and
contradict each other but that's okay
because what's true for you is true for
you and what's true for me is true for
me that's the idea there
number two the Bible contains the word
of God but is not in and of itself the
word of God that's the existential
Viewpoint and letter number three
underneath that inspiration is
quantitative rather than qualitative
there's an amounts of inspiration you
may be more or less inspired than myself
quality of inspiration has nothing to do
with it the message has nothing to do
with it it's how you feel about how
inspired you may feel about you know or
whatever you're communicating
yes
sure
we're going to get to that okay
letter E the net result of accepting
this view can be summed up as follows
number one the Bible is no longer the
final Authority in all matters of Truth
and number two the reader becomes the
authority as to what for him or her is
inspired
and we you know this is what we're
seeing a lot today and well you know
what's again what's true for you is true
for you what's true for me is true for
me
um you're your own authority there's no
absolute
letter F in Practical terms this leads
to disbelief in the biblical creation
account the divine nature of Christ the
Virgin birth the resurrection Etc
because sure the ex the the personal
experience of the Prophet at the time
felt that that was a reality but we know
today that it wasn't a reality but
subjectively it was true for them
you kind of follow that
it's a bunch of garbage really but it is
a Viewpoint okay
we as seven of the Adventists in in this
next section
our view of inspiration number one
second Timothy 3 16 we've looked at
before all scriptures given by
inspiration of God not part of it all of
it that word inspiration is the word as
you see there theat nustos which means
god breathed okay
all scriptures God breathed and number
two holy man of God were what
moved by the Holy Spirit we believe that
God spoke we believe he spoke through
men those men were moved by the Holy
Spirit
that uh uh underneath that you have two
different translation readings on that
the word moved is also translated in the
Good News Bible as under the control of
the Holy Spirit
and in the ESV carried Along by the Holy
Spirit the idea is that the prophet was
clearly is the word as the Bible is
teaching here the point is getting
across is the prophet was clearly guided
by the Holy Spirit but holy men of God
were moved by the Holy Spirit it was
still Humanity conveying the Divine
message
and that next one I want you to look at
with me second Corinthians 4 7. I've got
it there but let's open our Bibles to
Second Corinthians chapter 4 and verse
7.
second Corinthians chapter four
and verse 7.
and I want somebody to read that for me
please who wants to read
yes
go ahead
second
Corinthians 4 7. but we have this
treasure
okay we have this treasure in what
Earthen vessels nothing fancy
uh Earthen vessels clay jars
that the Excellence of the power might
be of God and not of us there's no
excellence in a clay jar it's pretty
ordinary it's pretty plain that's all
Paul's saying God has used plain things
it's the same thing he says in First
Corinthians chapter two that God has
used the foolish things of the world to
confound the wise
God uses humble holy men men who have
submitted to his leading and speaks by
inspiration through these men
we have this treasure in Earthen vessels
that the Excellence may be seen that it
might be seen the Excellency has comes
from God and not from man
letter A
First Timothy 3 16 says the mystery of
godliness is the union of divinity and
Humanity
this Union was perfectly manifested in
the life of Jesus Christ the god-man
it is also manifested in the inspiration
process as God communicates
unapproachable light as first Timothy 3
16 says through the Fallen human
channels
look at the statements there below these
are from some Adventist sources the
first one is from the handbook of
Seventh Day Adventist Theology and we're
just establishing the Adventist
understanding of inspiration
truly the scriptures are fully human and
fully divine
any idea that some parts of the Bible
are merely human while other parts are
divinely inspired contradicts the way
the biblical writers present the matter
Paul's words that all scriptures God
breathed do not allow for any concept of
partial inspiration
neither are there any hints in scripture
suggesting degrees of inspiration and
that was something that went around in
the time of Desmond Ford they went to
talking about degrees of inspiration
well Ellen White was a prophet Desmond
Ford said but she was not as much a
prophet as the Bible prophets she was a
lesser degree of a prophet we don't
believe that there are lesser degrees of
profits which we'll see in a moment we
believe that the gift of the inspiration
of God is given it's the inspiration of
God
God gives inspiration it's inspiration
it's not degrees of inspiration
and that's all this is pointing out
some portions of scripture may be more
important than other portions
Jesus speaks in Matthew 23 23 about the
weightier matters of the law there may
be some important some parts of
scripture that God may say are more
present truth you might say
but that does not mean that they are
more inspired
every Christian would do well to receive
the words of Holy scripture not as the
word of men
but as what it really is the word of God
as Paul says in first Thessalonians 2
13. now that's the that's the what the
SDA Handbook of uh theology says in
regard to our understanding of
inspiration
from Seventh Day Adventist believe page
eight
it says these Revelations were embodied
in human language with all its
limitations and Imperfections yet they
remained God's testimony
God inspired what
God inspired men not words
in some instances writers were commanded
to express the exact words of God talked
about the Ten Commandments but in most
cases God instructed them to describe to
the best of their ability what they saw
or heard
next section
or letter three
number three
Ellen White says in first uh selected
messages page 21.
the writers of the Bible were God's pen
men not his pen
look at the different writers it is not
the words of the Bible that are inspired
but the men that were inspired
inspiration acts not only I'm sorry not
on the man's words or his expressions
but on the man himself who under the
influence of the Holy Ghost is imbued
with thoughts
but the words receive the impress of the
individual mind
the Divine mind is diffused
so that's how she says she comes to the
conclusion of or that's her her
statement of how the Bible was inspired
going right along with what we just read
from from the other gentleman and from
what we saw in the word of God now this
next section this is the sticky section
and I understand this
there are different viewpoints and I'm
going to tell you why we're covering
what we are here inerrancy infallibility
of the scripture
the section says there under number one
the scripture is the inspired word of
God all of it how much of it all of it
as such the question is asked can it
contain any error the initial response
would be impossible
yet it must be remembered and maintained
that though God is inerrant and
infallible yet the human channels used
in communicating his messages were not
as we just briefly studied in our last
section
holy men of God spoke but notice they
were still men
and we're going to touch on this in a
minute because I know you're going to
have some questions
look at the first statement there also
from first selected messages uh page 20.
the Bible is not given to us in Grand
superhuman language
Jesus in order to reach man where he is
took Humanity the Bible must be given in
the language of man
everything that is human is imperfect
different meanings are expressed by the
same word there is not one word for each
distinct idea the Bible was given for
practical purposes men communicated in
their own language that's all it's
saying
number two in regard to infallibility
she says I never claimed it God Alone is
infallible his word is true and in him
is no variables variableness or shadow
of turning
uh for selected messages page 37 and we
talked about degrees of inspiration just
one thing we'll look at quickly first
John chapter three I'm not I'm sorry not
first John John chapter 3 Matthew Mark
Luke John
and verse 34 Matthew Mark Luke John who
wants to read John 3 34 for us please
John 3 34 who wants to read that okay
go ahead for he whom God hath sent
speaketh the words of God for God giveth
not the Spirit by measure okay
now that unto him what is it what does
it look like in your Bible
it's italicized what does that tell us
it's added what the Bible says what that
text says is God does not give the
spirit what
by measure if God gives the Holy Spirit
he gives the Holy Spirit if God gives
you a gift you get the gift you don't
get a partial gift you don't get 80 of
the Holy Spirit you either get the
spirit or you don't you follow that the
Bible doesn't teach anything like a
degree of inspiration you're either
inspired or you're not inspired you
follow that
now this is the next part that we're
looking at here and this is the one I
want to spend some time with number two
categories of Errors mistakes
discrepancies call them what you will
we know that when we get into the Bible
there are things that don't add up
okay whether they're copyist errors
whether they're translators errors
whether they were the prophets errors
now
when we get into this discussion I was
talking I've talked with several people
about this this week I was talking with
pastor ashrik about it just last night
there are different viewpoints on the
air and sea in the Bible especially in
the original autographs of the Bible
okay
in other words when Paul wrote what he
wrote when Luke wrote what he wrote were
there any errors in that
now
do you know what the uh do you know what
the position of our church is on that
what's that bubble but not but not in
Aaron
infallible but not inerrant good point
good point
that is the position the position of of
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church on this
and I'll tell you why is
that there is the possibility of errors
in the original autographs
okay
that's not everybody doesn't view it
that way
but I'll tell you what's going to happen
and I'll tell let me give you a little
bit more uh broaden this out for you a
little bit
we don't have the original autographs of
scripture you know that
okay so so the errors may be in there
they may not be in there we can maintain
that they're not in there nobody can
prove different but we do have the
original autographs of Ellen White and
let me tell you something they contain
errors
and if we want to hold a view of
inspiration
that says there's no error in the
original autograph
I'm going to take a half I have to take
a hard look at our profit
do you understand that
and we're going to look at some of these
we're going to look at some of these
here and I'm going to explain
um
we're going to talk specifically about
the errors we're just going to go
through the types of errors that we find
discrepancies mistakes
and a lot of some of them are in well
let's just look at some of them and then
I'll take questions when we finish up
here first of all there's the there's
the category that of of what we would
call we could break those errors down
into three categories unfulfilled
prophecies
small matters of minor detail and
significant matters of major detail okay
first one we're going to look at briefly
is unfulfilled prophecies we've already
touched on this
unfulfilled prophecies we mentioned
Jonah earlier today
somebody could look at Jonah and say
well that was an error Jonah said that
and I'm not talking you know I'm not
saying that all of these are errors but
I'm saying this is what people accuse is
being heirs in the scripture Jonah
that's another that's an error because
Jonah said an interview would be
destroyed and Innova wasn't destroyed
okay
well that's the matter of an unfulfilled
of a rather of a conditional prophecy
right
we've already talked about that today
you follow
I'm going to pause here and I'm going to
have everybody stand up
I want you to stretch
I'm going to take some deep breaths I'm
going to open this back up
I'm going to turn this on
yeah it's getting a little warm in here
now isn't it
very comfortable and this is probably
one of the most important things we look
at
all right
and if you would like to do you can sit
down now if you'd like to do that in the
middle of class you're welcome to if
that's what it takes to keep you awake
thank you
Jonah is an example of a conditional
prophecy was it an error not really
it's just that somebody didn't
understand the nature of conditional
prophecies in the same way we can look
at the prophecies regarding Israel's
glory for example the worldwide mission
of ancient Israel the in-gathering of
the Gentiles the Eternal rest in Cain
and the deliverance from their political
enemies all of these all of these
expectations for ancient Israel have
brought us into this Distortion of
Prophecy today where everybody's saying
well Israel is going to go back to their
own land and all this other stuff
because they don't understand that many
of those prophecies were conditional to
ancient Israel
and of those God will fulfill many of
those two
spiritual Israel
but there are some people saying no God
made those prophecies in ancient Israel
and they must come to pass because you
know God's word cannot air
but if it's a conditional prophecy God's
word didn't there you follow that
okay
so there's the area of unfulfilled
prophecies I'm sorry of of uh
conditional prophecies
why are they unfulfilled and the only
only prophecies we really find from a
true Prophet that isn't fulfilled is is
a conditional prophecy
uh
number three there the food for worms
Vision are you familiar with this Vision
have you heard about the food for
wormsuition where Ellen White stood and
spoke to a congregation and said that uh
of the congregation she said an angel
revealed to me that in this congregation
today some of these people here are
going to be food for worms some of these
people are going to be subject to the
seven last plagues and some of them are
going to see Jesus come
are you familiar with that Vision if
you're not you can read it I don't have
the reference there let me get you the
reference between this and the next
class
so now you can have your projector back
too if you need it
whenever you need it
all right
the vision was received on Tuesday May
27 1856 the youngest person in the crowd
was Willie white a babe in his mother's
arm he died in 1937 at the age of 83.
people said people were keeping track of
who was there at the vision Illinois
says that before all these people died
Jesus is going to come again
some of them are going to go pass on to
the Grave some of them are going to be
subject to the seven last place some
will see Jesus come and so they kept and
the youngest one was Willie white so
once everybody else had died it was like
well he's got to come before Willie dies
he's got to come before Willie dies
but they hadn't factored in
that that prophecy was a conditional
prophecy
plain and simple
if God's people in Illinois has said
this on a number of occasions she said
if God's people had gone to work right
after 1844 the Lord aired this would
have come
but he hasn't come why
because God's people didn't go to work
do you follow that
okay so there are prophecies that
haven't been fulfilled not because the
prophet was a false prophet in this case
for example but because the prophecy was
conditional
yes sir
huh I didn't I I'll have to get it at
the break
it's in the book by the way I just I
didn't put a reference down I apologize
now the next section small matters of
minor detail there are matters in the
scripture you've seen them that of minor
detail
that are discrepancies
and I know that we can go to Great
Lengths and I've seen some people go to
to uh research and really have come with
some real plausible solutions to some of
these discrepancies but here's a point
that I would make
you're going to have a tendency to cut
your own nose off to spite your face if
you take this route
you know why Walter Ray left the
Adventist Church and wrote the book The
White Lie because he was convinced that
there was no error in any of the
originals it was verbal inspiration and
what do you think happened when he found
out
well let's take the verbal inspiration
Viewpoint for a minute
in verbal inspiration
if Ellen White borrowed from another
Rider what's that maker
no not just a plagiarist
a false prophet
if I'm a verbal inspirationist God said
word for word write this if I said
here's an interesting phrase I'm going
to incorporate In this passage suddenly
I'm a false prophet
and so Walter Ray when he came across
that
Ellen White's a false prophet and and I
can't tell you how many cases of people
that have fallen into that like DM cam
right and others who've gotten into that
mindset of verbal inspiration and
therefore when they find a discrepancy
in the writings of Ellen White
she's a false prophet
but let's look at for an example some of
these discrepancies
we went through I went through with
through a few with Pastor asterisk now
you know these are the critics
discrepancies and some of them really
have no basis we went through a few in
there so that's not a discrepancy at all
uh for example
um well I've got I've included different
ones here so we'll look at them
in the first Passage
was the toll in David's battle against
the Syrian Army 40 000 footmen
as it says in first Chronicles 19 18 or
Horsemen as it says in second Samuel 10
18. I want somebody to read one of each
Okay who wants to read uh First
Chronicles 19 18.
will you read it Kevin and then uh
um second Samuel 10 18. yes sir Ivan
look those up for us
and I have different types of
uh
discrepancies in Minor Details here so
that we can see the different types that
appear in the scripture
First Chronicles 19 18 do you have it
okay
very good
now second Samuel 10 18.
one of the syrians the men of 700
chariots and 40 000 foreign
okay now one says Horsemen once says
footman does somebody pick up one
number of insurance
okay
the number of Chariots was different
yeah
does anybody have something else yes sir
okay
okay now in in my in my Bible does
anybody have marginal readings in your
Bible
like a center column reference or
something
okay in my Bible in verse 18 for the for
the marginal reading it says um the
syrians fled before Israel and David
killed seven thousand charioteers my
margin says 700.
okay that's an alternate reading and it
says uh forty thousand foot soldiers but
my margin gives an alternate reading of
Horsemen
okay that's an alternate reading in the
original language it could be taken as
both
so for example I'm telling you that not
all of these are glaring errors but when
a person comes and looks at this upon
their first reading they're looking at
this and they're saying well look at
that which one is it there's a
discrepancy well the discrepancy may
just be based on the translation from
the original languages do you follow
that okay so that's a possibility there
are those types of Errors you're going
to find in the Bible neither neither way
it's it's neither is significant is it
in a huge way as far as the effecting of
of personal salvation do you follow that
okay there's one example let's look at
the let's look at the next example I'm
not going to look the texts up here I
think you've probably covered this
before
was Christ confronted at gergesa by one
demoniac or by two
well you have different accounts in the
scripture but what's the answer
huh probably two what's the problem with
the one that said one
let's go back to our video
is it possible for you to take in the
whole scene and not get the detail
somebody else does let's say that
there's demoniacs there but one of them
is just screaming mad and crazy he's
maybe a little more prominent than the
other one so we're watching the video
one of you is like man that guy's
freaked me out and you writing down
there's this demoniac singular
but another one of you who's not quite
as freaked out a little more observant
says yeah but there's a guy in the
background too there's two of the
demoniacs there in that picture do you
follow that yeah when you're dealing
with thought inspiration that's fully
feasible isn't it that somebody you've
got different perspectives okay
none of the evangelists there said there
was only one demoniac right so there's a
discrepancy there somebody looking at
that is going to say hey there's a
discrepancy in the scripture but it may
just be uh that you've got different
viewpoints or the same scene are you
following me on that yeah the next one
this one's a little more challenging
I want somebody to look up Luke 18 35
who wants to do that for me
Luke 18 35.
okay Ivan and uh and uh Mark 10 46 who's
going to look that one up for me
Mark 10 46 all right
Luke 18 35 and Mark 10 46.
Mark 1845 uh Luke 18 35 sorry Luke 18 35
and Mark 10 46 Luke 18 35 Ivan could you
read that for us
[Music]
okay as Jesus what
approached Jericho there was a blind man
there begging okay now who who has uh
read the
Mark 10 46.
out of Jericho with his disciples a
great number of people
and a great number of people blind
Bartimaeus the son of Emmaus Sat by the
highway side baby okay now it says he's
going out of Jericho
question did he heal the blind man on
his way into Jericho on his way out of
Jericho
is that
now here's my here's my point before I
get to the next one
you know I was talking with elder
Gallimore about this I've talked with
I've talked with several people about
this by the by the way just just getting
different takes on this I can tell you
what I feel about it
but the consensus is this I may as well
just tell you what I feel about it
it doesn't shake my faith
if the Desi if the Apostle who saw the
vision
and communicated it thought that they're
on the way out instead of the way in
I don't think that destroys the
inspiration of the scripture
there are some who will want to get well
let's see can we resolve all of these
things
it's irrelevant to me
I've not lost my faith in the scripture
and I hold the Viewpoint with with with
uh plenary inspiration with thought
inspiration it's possible to have
different not only different
um
not only different viewpoints
but even in this case look Jesus was
either coming or he was going
he was either doing one or the other
he passed through and he either healed
the man coming in or going out
one of the guys is wrong
is that going to destroy the faith of
the script is that going to destroy the
message of the scriptures I don't see
that that would be the case
and I'll tell you where this really
comes home
when we get in when we get into this
next section in Ella White's writings
there's going to be discrepancies there
that you're not going to be able to
solve and we sit around and say well in
the scripture we did and here's what
you're going to end up with
you're going to end up with different
inspiration of a Bible prophet
from Ellen White
or you're going to take the
understanding of plenary inspiration and
say you know what it's all possible that
there were things that were erroneous
but God preserved the content and the
core of the message
and now you have consistency all the way
through
and I've seen this happen I've seen
people who want to maintain
well there's no mistakes and I've seen
him go out of the church because they
can't reconcile the two
and when I asked Elder Gallum I said
Elder galmore what's your take on this
he says you know what he says well we
looked at the next one let's look at the
next one I'm not going to look the texts
up
who wrote The Prophecy foretelling the
Betrayal of Christ for 30 pieces of
silver Jeremiah as Matthew quotes or
Zechariah now I've heard the different
answers for this
but I told this I was talking without a
gallon he says you know what he says if
Matthew wrote Jeremiah and he met
Zechariah it wouldn't shake my faith in
the slightest in the scripture and the
authority the total authority of the
scripture
now there are groups of people who will
take these things and say
because Matthew misquoted or whatever
therefore that part of the scripture is
uninspired that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying under inspiration because of
the nature of inspiration thought
inspiration
there are details and possibilities that
Matthew could have wrote down
you could have said Zechariah when you
meant or said Jeremiah we met Zechariah
I've done it you've heard people do it
when they preach you've done it
sometimes in a Bible study well you know
Ellen White did this and there's a
passage I don't have it on here where
she said just like the Apostle Paul
wrote in
um or just like the Apostle Peter said
in First Corinthians chapter
the Apostle who
Peter First Corinthians
but she said it she wrote it what would
you do with that copyist no it's not a
copyist we have Ellen White's
manuscripts handwritten we can see it we
can check it out
and that's where these enemies have come
in and said well look at that there's an
error
but because of our understanding of
inspiration it doesn't shake our faith
in it do you understand that
we'll pick up on this a little bit more
after the break we'll get into a little
bit more detail we'll look at some of
these issues in Ellen White's writings
and kind of
hit this a little bit harder okay and
we'll take any questions that you may
have